lo que quiero ver en este vídeo es
proporcionarles una definición formal
sobre qué significa tomarme el límite de
una sucesión cuando n tiende a infinito
que por cierto esta forma de definir
este límite es muy parecida a la forma
de definirla a cualquier función su
límite cuando tiene infinito y esto
tiene toda la lógica del mundo porque
podemos ver a las sucesiones como una
función que depende de los índices pero
bueno vamos a graficar aquí a una
sucesión que por cierto no es pérez pero
déjeme quitar esta línea de aquí y
mejora voy a poner por acá para que
veamos a qué me refiero cuando el límite
de una sucesión cuando n tiende a
infinito tiendan a un valor entonces
vamos a suponer que éste es igual a 1 ya
que me da aún a 1 estás en igualados ya
que me da un a 2 a subíndice 2 en
igualdad 3 me da un a sub 20 3 aquí
tengo un n igual a 4 aquí un subíndice 4
y aquí un n igual a 5 con su respectivo
al subíndice 5 y bueno si te das cuenta
esta sucesión parece que tiende
a un cierto valor que voy a definir por
aquí esta sucesión está saltando pero a
su vez está acercándose y acercándose y
acercándose a un cierto valor por aquí
que voy a llamar él entonces aquí tengo
mis nn uno dos tres cuatro cinco aquí
tengo mi guel que es mi valor al cual se
está acercando esta asociación y si yo
quiero definir de una manera formal que
mi sucesión
n se va acercando al valor de l cuando
entiendo infinito entonces mi definición
formal de este límite sería sí para toda
épsilon mayor que cero
tú puedes encontrar o tú me puedes dar a
un nuevo espera espera porque esto no
suena tan elegante mejor lo voy a poner
de la siguiente manera si para toda
épsilon mayor que cero
existe una n positiva existe una m
positiva tal que pase lo siguiente si
tomamos cualquier en el más grande que m
no olvides que n es el subíndice que
existen los naturales si tomamos
cualquier n más grande que m entonces la
diferencia entre a n
l
el valor al que nos vamos a acercar en
valor absoluto es menor que epsilon a
ver a ver a ver vamos a decirle otra vez
si para toda épsilon mayor que 0 existe
m positiva tal que si tomamos cualquier
n más grande que m entonces el valor
absoluto de la n menos él es menor que
pilón justo en este caso si esto pasa
entonces decimos que el límite de a n
cuando n tiende a infinito es igual a l
o como vimos en el vídeo pasado esto es
exactamente lo mismo que decir que a n
convergen a l la sucesión a en él
convergen al valor de l y bueno como
esto es una definición es un sí sólos y
aquí tenemos la declaración sobre a qué
me refiero cuando digo que la asociación
a n convergen a l y bueno de nada sirve
tener aquí esta declaración de nada
sirve tener aquí esta definición si no
entendemos a qué me refiero cuando esta
definición así que vamos a intentar
entender mejor que me está diciendo todo
esto imagínate que yo tengo una cierta
épsilon más grande que 0 y por lo tanto
aquí
l más épsilon de aquí l épsilon lo que
sí le estoy pidiendo a épsilon es que
sea más grande que 0 y bueno me estoy
tomando aquí a una épsilon arbitraria y
entonces sí para todas
épsilon arbitraria existe una m positiva
ahora bien si para esta eps ido en medio
que 0 encuentro una m positiva así que
en este caso voy a decir que este es mi
valor de m me voy a tomar m igualados
ahora dice si para esta épsilon positiva
encuentro una m positiva tal que para
todos los valores más grandes que m es
decir para cualquier en el más grande
que m n puede ser 3 456 etcétera sí para
estos valores yo me fijo en la distancia
que hay de aena l esto es esencialmente
lo que está diciendo esto si en este
rango verde entra la distancia que hay
de aa n aire es decir que si a partir de
ahorita todos los puntos caen dentro de
este rango esto es lo que quiere decir
que sea menor que épsilon si la
distancia que hay dehaene a él es menor
que epsilon
entonces mi sucesión con bergia l y de
hecho aquí lo podemos ver visualmente
porque para toda n mayor que 2 fíjate
que los puntos se van acercando y
acercando y acercando a él es decir que
esta distancia está haciendo cada vez
más delgada justo por eso pedimos que
usted para toda épsilon y si esto pasa
entonces este límite existe y la
sucesión a en en convergen a él y justo
lo que quiero ver en el siguiente vídeo
es utilizar esta definición para ver que
una sucesión converge